the book was really Britain's as a
letter to a younger version of myself
who didn't realize that the journey
itself is more important than this
destination I was really caught up for
my very first year of graduate school
and we all used to think about what
could we do to win a Nobel prizes the
ultimate a plus
but along the way when you focus on
these awards say an actor just purely
focused on winning an Oscar or a
director that causes a person to have
tunnel vision to focus intently on just
achieving a single goal and I think that
goal orientation reflects and can do
damage to to a scientist integrity into
the way that they conduct themselves I
[Music]
think it actually in many cases is
punishing scientists and setting up
artificial collaborations that
disintegrate because the competition
that exists to win the Nobel Prize to
compete for the dwindling amount of
resources that are available and also
that the the prize is really not
representative of the spectrum that is
modern science its diverse its men and
women it's from all countries it's not
just three people at most sitting in a
room I think it's it's demeaning to
science to say that this is the ultimate
thing to aspire for whereas the
scientific journey is reward and should
be rewarded in itself
[Music]
and I think we have to act now
I think it's an urgent time we can
actually transform it before it's too
late
change is difficult and I think my book
is written in such a way to give
concrete ideas for people to transform
this accolade so that it is this guild
of lustrous thing that is worthy of
aspiration and in doing so reflect how
science is done today
[Music]